vote with our dollars about the things
that we care about
and if you show me what someone is
spending their money and their time out
i can tell you what their future is if
someone is just really sticking hard i'm
not sure it's a fit for me when you're
talking to somebody who's trying to lose
weight and they're like i can't afford a
gym membership and you're like girl
you're spending 200 bucks on your nails
and you've got a thousand dollar outfit
on do you think another thousand dollar
outfit would make you look better or
your high school weight so this one is
new identity and priorities when you
have a new identity
you have new priorities
and so you've had priorities that are
aligned with your old identity right
there's the you that goes out to you the
drinks that you that does the blah blah
blah spends money on [ __ ] you shouldn't
do spends time on [ __ ] you shouldn't be
spending time on it
and there's the you that you want to be
it's right now you can draw the line in
the sand and be like do you want to keep
walking down the road that you have been
walking
and if you don't
then you have to step into new identity
and with that new identity comes through
priorities